hey 42 here Irv is full of perilous
places from the frozen wastelands of
Antarctica all the way to leafy England
let's take a look at the ten most
dangerous places on earth first up is
Antarctica Antarctica is one of the
largest land masses on earth covering an
enormous 14 million square kilometers
yet it only has around 5000 temporary
residents and 0 permanent residents
making it the least densely populated
country on earth and it's no surprise
when you consider its extreme weather
conditions the temperature has been
known to go as low as 90 degrees Celsius
couple up with the astonishing wind
speeds of up to 327 kilometers per hour
and you've got one of the most dangerous
climates on earth even protected you
wouldn't last longer than an hour in
Antarctica next up is the Danakil desert
situated in Northeast Ethiopia it has
been named by National Geographic as the
cruelest place on earth it's a scary
100,000 square kilometer area of
extremely hot and arid terrain where
daily temperatures regularly surpass 50
degrees Celsius the desert is also home
to the Danakil depression a basin that
lies a hundred metres below sea level
which is home to many active volcanoes
and suffers frequent earthquakes it's
one of the hottest driest and most
violent places on earth because of this
nobody lives there except a few brave
salt miners oh and to top it off travel
to the Danakil desert area is strongly
discouraged by most international
governments because there's an extremely
high threat of kidnapping in the area
and border tensions between Ethiopia and
the neighboring country
of eritrea up next is the Guatemala
sinkhole sinkholes are a natural
phenomenon caused by the erosion of
underground rock by rainwater when too
much rock has eroded the ground
spectacularly falls in on itself
creating an enormous sinkhole these
happen all over the world but some
places are more susceptible than others
such as Florida Texas and Guatemala one
of the most devastating sinkholes
occurred in 2010 in Guatemala when a 20
metre round hole appeared suddenly in
the ground swallowing off an entire
three-story factory the hole it left
behind is 30 metres deep
the sinkhole occurred because of a
combination of recent events namely the
recent tropical storm Agatha
a nearby volcano erupting and leaking
sewer pipes needless to say if you visit
Guatemala you better watch your step
just off the coast of South Paulo in
Brazil is an island nicknamed snake
island the island is riddled with a
unique species of snake called the
golden lancehead Viper which is one of
the most venomous snakes in the world it
is reported that there are as many as
five snakes in every square meter of the
island the venom of the golden lancehead
Viper is so deadly but it melts away
human flesh whilst a powerful neurotoxin
quickly shuts down your central nervous
system because the island is so
hazardous access to the island has been
banned by the Brazilian government apart
from a select few scientists who monitor
the snakes lake nyos is a crater lake in
the Northwest region of Cameroon this
poisonous lake sits above volcanic earth
magma below the surface releases massive
amounts of carbon dioxide into the lake
which is stockpiled in a layer at the
bottom of the lake
the levels of carbon dioxide at the
bottom of the lake gets too high the
lake explodes suffocating anyone and
everything in close proximity to the
lake
the last time this happened was in 1986
when the lake suddenly emitted a large
cloud of carbon dioxide that suffocated
1,700 people and 3,500 livestock in
surrounding towns and villages it was
the first recorded large-scale a fixie
ation caused by a natural event Bolivia
is home to the infamous young gas road
more commonly known as the road of death
it's an extremely narrow mountain road
that connects la paz to coroico it's
especially dangerous during rainy season
and has been named by the inter-american
Development Bank as the world's most
dangerous road around 300 travelers are
killed on the road every year the
roadside is scattered with crosses that
mark the spots where travelers have
fallen to their deaths the North
Anatolian fault is an enormous faults
that runs along most of Turkey during
the past century there have been a
series of devastating earthquakes along
the North Anatolian fault of magnitude
above a seven they have been
progressively creeping west along the
fold heading towards Istanbul which is
next on the list to be struck by the
fault lines devastating earthquakes the
last devastating earthquake was in 1999
in Ismet the 7.4 magnitude quake killed
seventeen thousand four hundred and
eighty people and injured 43 thousand
959 people but that could be nothing
compared to what will happen when the
earthquake hits the Turkish capital of
Istanbul with a population of 14 point
two million people and it will hit it
this imminent disaster has been deemed
an in
ability it's just a matter of when
geophysicists estimates the likelihood
of Istanbul being hit by a magnitude 7
or greater earthquake in the next 20
years is around 60% such a disaster will
be very bad news for millions of
residents making Istanbul one of the
most dangerous places to live
droughts don't often get as much
attention as over more spectacular
natural disasters but they can be one of
the most deadly the Sahel region of
Africa which borders the Sahara Desert
is one of the most drought prone places
in the world according to the United
Nations an astonishing 100,000 people
died due to droughts in the Sahel region
of Africa between 1972 and 1984 another
750,000 were unable to grow their crops
and had to completely rely on food aid
instead next we go to England
specifically the on WIC poison gardens
in Northumberland the garden is
specifically designed to securely grow
and protect hundreds of highly poisonous
and narcotic plants behind locked cages
grow some of the deadliest plants known
to man such as belladonna tobacco and
Mandrake and finally and arguably the
most dangerous place on earth because of
other humans is Honduras this Central
American country has the highest murder
rate in the world after 90 homicides per
100,000 people and what's more the
second biggest city in Honduras San
Pedro Sula has the highest homicide rate
of any city in the world with 169
murders occurring for every 100,000
residents this is primarily due to drug
violence ever since Honduras became the
key staging post for cocaine smuggling
from South America to the US the
murder rate has skyrocketed year-on-year
thanks for the view subscribe for more